and what could be a
huge change for the future of movie
going in this country some of the
biggest
upcoming blockbusters will head straight
to streaming
warner brothers announced all of its
upcoming movies from dune and wonder
woman 1984
to the new tom and jerry movie will be
on hbo max
on the same day they hit theaters wow
they say it's only through 2021 though
but as carter evans shows us
it could have a devastating impact on
movie theaters which have already
been hit very hard by this pandemic
releasing a movie simultaneously in
theaters
and online was almost unheard of
less than a year ago get used to it but
when wonder woman 1984 premieres on
christmas day
in theaters and streaming on hbo max
it'll be the first of warner brothers
entire 2021 roster of new movies
to be released in theaters and on its
streaming service hbo max
at the same time it sort of redefines
what a blockbuster looks like
matt donnelly is a senior film writer
for variety
is this the beginning of the end of
movie theaters as we know it
i would say absolutely they're suffering
incredible losses
financially layoffs and now we're
heading into another round of extreme
closures
so i think movie theaters as we know
them will ultimately change warner
brothers is holding
nothing back releasing 17 of the most
anticipated films of the year
including suicide squad
a remake of the classic doom
and the lin-manuel miranda adaptation in
the heights
it's time to make some noise how does
this work financially for warner
brothers
the incentive here for warner brothers
is to drive subscriber growth for when
all 17 movies come out
they'll have an incredibly higher number
of subscribers than they do now
something that can rival disney and
netflix
in a statement the ceo of theater chain
amc
accused the movie studio of sacrificing
profit
for subscribers saying we will do all in
our power to ensure that warner
does not do so at our expense so far
this year theaters are grossing about
two billion dollars in the u.s compared
to
11 billion last year so they said that
they're only going to do this for one
year
but can you put that genie back in the
bottle you can't sort of train your
subscribers to expect these incredible
massive productions for free on hbo max
and after a year tell them sorry no
you're going to have to go see matrix 5
in theaters
the films will be available to
subscribers at no
extra charge but they'll stop streaming
after 30 days
it sounds like this is great news for
movie viewers oh my god absolutely
especially for people who have been sort
of trapped inside or have
suffered a drought of content so if you
can watch wonder woman 1984
and then zoom with your family about it
i mean i'm sure that these are
experiences people would hope they could
have together in theaters but now
they'll still be able to
um for the price of a monthly
subscription for
cbs this morning carter evans what did
you do
los angeles what did you do
i think it's great out of the box
thinking on the part of warner brothers
but i hope it really is just for 2021 i
still love going to the movie
i don't think that's going to change but
i do think i think the pandemic is
forcing changes in a lot of ways in a
lot of industries restaurants i don't
think will quite ever be the same either
you know and i think you know i think
all these things will be taken into
account as
as we evolve out of this but gail you're
right movie theaters are incomparable
the popcorn the picture
the other people
the fact you don't have to clean up the
floor afterwards and if you stain the
seat it's not your couch that's my
problem sometimes the theaters don't
clean up the floor
look for an increase in big tv sales for
2021